but what was astounding Allen is at ten
sessions of neurofeedback I could calm
the body without ever once talking about
who you killed or who tried to kill you
and what we found out at Camp Pendleton
clinically amongst us you do 10 12 15
sessions and your feedback then somebody
wants to talk about how the [ __ ] can
there be a God given with what I did or
with what I saw in war how can there be
a God then you can have that kind of
conversation without losing your stuff
without becoming activated so the the
great benefit is the ability to regulate
the central nervous system without
talking about what happened when you
were a little boy or when you were a
little girl you're not avoiding it but
you are leaving it up to that
consciousness to approach that subject
when they are ready and that's one of
the greatest benefits to this and that's
why I really left talk therapy behind
when I was in that training and when I
came back from being awake for two days
I sat next to a psychiatrist and we were
talking and they said something up there
and I leaned over and I whispered I said
there goes the DSM out the window and it
was I agree boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake and we are still at consciousness
hackings awakened future summit we are
now gonna be speaking to dr. Michael
Villanueva hello hello thanks so much
for coming on the show really appreciate
it I'm tickled an honor to be here I'm
very excited it's gonna be a lot of fun
Michael is the founder of Alpha Theta
Center where they're training the brain
to neural efficiency so Michael let's
start things off with who you are and
what you represent I am a clinical
psychologist and I have been trained and
clinical talk therapy and whatnot and
with a union kind of with a union a bit
of a Jungian background so when I came
back from Afghanistan about five six
years ago
I had taken certain technology into this
combat zone I realized that I wanted to
work with the brain in a different way
so I started with the help of actually a
couple of officers that seriously
donated funds which surprised the hell
out of me
I started up the company but it became
clear to me the purpose of the company
in the mission actually it's in the
mission statement is for the protection
and enhancement of consciousness because
of a became very clear to me that
consciousness whatever this thing is and
however we define it is possibly one of
the most precious things that we've
encountered so far and like I say in the
universe we have no idea what's in the
universe but that was the driving
impetus to start the Alpha Theta Center
whoa okay so what was how the work in
clinical psychology from prior to
Afghanistan what were you doing in
clinical psychology and then how did you
get to Afghanistan what have you been
doing since then talk talk talk therapy
talk talk talk talk therapy I was at
Camp Pendleton and I was doing talk
therapy and the some of the
psychologists there were working with
neurofeedback and they told me I should
work with this and and being the
self-righteous arrogant male that I am a
hundred percent of the time I said I
don't need to learn that and they said
it's really powerful I said if it was
that powerful I would have learned about
it in graduate school so I poo pooed it
but my boss commander Bane asked me
again if I would go to the training and
because it was a contractor she couldn't
order me to and then next year she asked
me to go again more vehemently and so I
went to the training and I had an
experience at the training when somebody
administered neurofeedback on me that
was impossible to reconcile with my
background it's a very simple thing I
had 12 minutes of whatever they did with
the electrodes and after that 12 minutes
was done I did not sleep for two days
except I was not wired I was not upset
I wasn't amped I wasn't feeling like I
was on coffee and I've driven across
Texas for 42 hours it wasn't like that I
was just awake when I did sleep
slept for 32 minutes woke up incredibly
refreshed had a great breakfast and said
what happened to me and that was my
foray back in 2009-2010 into
neurofeedback I was a reservist at the
time because when I was working on the
Hopi reservation I did a study there on
PTSD I realized at that age of late 40s
I'd never done my piece for the
community which is what drives a lot of
pueblos that join the militaries a sense
of community so I realized I've never
done my piece so I joined the Army
Medical Service Corps and so I was a
reservists so the opportunity came up I
heard about a chance for deployment to
Afghanistan and ironically I was kind of
prepping my sailboat to sail to the
South Pacific because I had in my mind
that was what I should do since I was in
my late 50s and instead I opted to take
a different type of deployment so I went
to Afghanistan but I took into a combat
zone the first psychologist to take
neurofeedback that hat was just an
amazing experience what happened there
and I had an interesting conversation
with the battalion surgeon this medical
guy so I knew I had to get him on my
side because the army didn't know what
neurofeedback was but since I'm a doctor
I said I'd do this and they said okay
excuse me but the funny part is I'm I
want the captain Rehder I said I'm you
know sir you know actually we were both
captains so I just I called everybody
sir
I said I have this thing called
neurofeedback and I think bah bah blah
blah I explained what it did and you
know what he said to me he says you know
if that was that powerful I would have
learned about this in medical school ha
ha ha I was thinking myself dude you and
I are gonna get a little good right so I
implemented in Afghanistan and there's a
whole Segway a whole sidebar about me
being here but in doing it the work I
was working with I was using two systems
one was the Signet neurofeedback by the
authors and they were very gracious and
given
the equipment to take there and and
that's that's good stuff it's there's no
doubt we've we've used we use many more
additional modalities but there's a
certain type of training called Alpha
Theta training which I think Jo Kamiya
way way back when had they started doing
and what this is it's just rolling the
dice it's it's rolling the dice with
electrodes you are encouraging the brain
to make alpha and theta together if so
what big deal well now I've come to
learn in the years past as I've moved
heavily into digital signal processing
how the EEG works that what we were
really doing it wasn't just
synchronizing because you know being in
sync everybody thinks it's cool right so
put your hand up for a second I know
it's a really kind of a silly example no
like that was this way yeah spread your
fingers okay so our fingers are in sync
right and we think that's cool right
yeah alright so but they're in sync but
imagine if those were two kind of
different waveforms like maybe like this
oh now they're in sync right how many
fingers you see quickly just answer the
question what if we offset the phase oh
the way of coming in from what do you
see in no time
yeah so the point is that obviously
waves carry and how there's phase is
offset information by encouraging the
synchrony and if you talk to any
clinician your feedback person who does
alpha theta training they will say yes
this taps into the unconscious well what
it did in Afghanistan was it just didn't
tap into the unconscious it seemed to
kind of and I know it sounds squirrelly
and I'm not a woowoo person but it
seemed to open doors into altered states
of perception and we had some very
unique interesting experiences that
happen in Afghanistan and there's not
the time and place to kind of get into
that but when I came back from there I
knew I wanted to take this to a wider
audience so my first thought when I came
back from deployment hey I'm gonna rock
it I'm gonna go to the VA
I'm apply at the VA so I applied at the
VA and I got offered a position right
those of that and all that sort of stuff
and but they wanted me to do interviews
like intakes I said no I can do
neurofeedback but I had no clue what it
was back then and they said no wewe know
we just want you to do in clinical
interviews so I said all right I'm not
doing that so I didn't work and I had
enough money banked in the bank to just
start traveling and so I started going
to different people trying to learn what
happened in Afghanistan and that started
this this road into EEG neurofeedback
and brain training and that road has
become exceptionally rocky and then
after it became rocky there is has been
no road and then I became an apostate
within my own community so I'm kind of
wandering lost in the desert at this
point I better stop talking right now
well let's let's go and let's go and
unpack this experience so okay so to
take us well let's let's go piece by
piece
shock therapy okay so normally you're
just I'm glad you brought that back yeah
so yes what happened with the talk
therapy stuff the problem with talk
therapy
my personal belief actually a
professional belief is that a hundred
years from now talk therapy is going to
be looked at as barbaric as leeches wow
that's a cool statement you also might
be cool but it also might be inaccurate
and that's and I'm not trying to slump
because it works there's so many more
biomarkers that we can yeah also and the
problem with talk therapy particularly
exposure therapy you are activating the
system and then getting it to unactive
eight that's true and so your
desensitizing the system and I get that
with exposure therapy so if somebody's
been in combat or somebody's been raped
you know let's talk about this over and
then you get activated and then you
bring the system down then you explore
more and you get activated and bring the
system down and it works there's no
doubt it works so it's bringing up
though you actually right and then and
then you calm the person down system
I think you sensitive how do you
normally calm the person you breathing
you reflect them with their body and
then wow they calm down so but the
problem I had with that I have to be
careful what I say here because I have a
metaphor that usually used is probably
not good for for the air the problem is
that it's barbaric we have a technology
now called neurofeedback and I went to
Fort Hood I was deployed for two weeks
to Fort Hood after the shootings there
and they were of course understandably
irritated because they didn't need help
but the army you know whatever the army
does is what the army does all go there
and help them like but dude they are the
army they got the wrong people
you're under orders go so I ended up
actually the PTSD clinic and I have some
amazing videos of sergeant Roberts on
our on our website but what was
astounding Allen is at ten sessions of
neurofeedback I could calm the body
without ever once talking about who you
killed or who tried to kill you and what
we found out at Camp Pendleton
clinically amongst us that you do 10 12
15 sessions and neurofeedback
then somebody wants to talk about how
the [ __ ] can there be a god given with
what I did or with what I saw in war how
can it be a god then you can have that
kind of conversation without losing your
stuff without becoming activated so that
the great benefit is the ability to
regulate the central nervous system
without talking about what happened when
you were a little boy or when you were a
little girl you're not avoiding it but
you are leaving it up to that
consciousness to approach that subject
when they are ready and that's one of
the greatest benefits to this and that's
why I really left talk therapy behind
when I was in that training and when I
came back from being awake for two days
i sat next to another psychiatrist and
we were talking and they said something
up there and I leaned over and I
whispered I said there goes the DSM out
the wind
and it goes I agree that that's an
insight thing where we do all sorts of
diagnostic work
yeah because Norbert whiner I think in
1955 and father of cybernetics I don't
remember where this was written and I'm
pretty certain he said this I hate to be
hate to misquote people but I believe he
said in 1955 some day all mental
disorders will be looked at as disorders
of communication that's exactly what
we're saying yeah when Tim and I were
talking downstairs that's one thing that
that was that the core of what we're
trying to understand is how does this
brain organize and process information
yes and the only way you're gonna get at
that is by looking at the EEG and not by
youqi youqi yak talk therapy is like you
know closing the barn door after the
horse has already left you are activated
milliseconds before you're even
consciously aware that you're upset I'm
how many times have you talked to
somebody and they've kind of just lost
their [ __ ] all of a sudden you know all
right chill man chill you what's going
on with them this stuff floods through
us with prior to conscious awareness and
then we struggle to say I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to call you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but just comes out yeah so if you
can calm the system if you put a few
milliseconds between the emergence you
know and you know close off the limbic
system and let and let the frontal
cortex say hold on a second because PTSD
and trauma is like acid on relationships
it's a very slow drip of acid it's not
like alien acid from aliens where it
instantly burns through no it's a very
gentle acid and over years and decades
it weakens the body it weakens
relationships and it isolates us and to
you go from a process that you say to be
barbaric I actually really enjoy this
way of phrasing it because I think being
able to leverage so much of the new
scientific advances that we have in the
bio signal processing and like you said
the disorders of communication this is
what it continues to come up over and
over in with the different leaders that
we sit with is that the more that we
study what's happening in the brain we
see that
of the ailments that we have today are
due to of disorders in communication of
the systems so okay now there's still so
much to unpack but I wanna I want to get
to this I want to get to the story at
Pendleton when you were stimulated and
then you had neuro neuro stimulation no
I didn't have no stimulation and I had
neuropathy then there are feedback so we
teach us about this the difference
well stimulation is when you put there's
two ways those multiple ways to
stimulate the brain but you put
something on the head and you put some
power into it whether it's a magnetic
pulse PMF I mean your cellphone's to
some degree stimulate the brain although
it's very very weak the newest one
excuse me these days is TMS trance
magnetic stimulation double cone can
actually reach deep into the brain kind
of stimulate areas at different
frequencies so that's stimulation the
zombie apocolypse method also works too
I've always my clients that case there's
a zombie apocalypse and you want to
stimulate the brain because you're
feeling depressed you know I give them
my secret zombie apocolypse formula for
that you know and if you can stem it
with DC current AC current you know so
that's stimulation electrical or
magnetic or this electrical or magnetic
are the - well there's also ultrasound
an ultrasound for stimulation right and
neurofeedback is just getting them
passive it's just reading the signals at
the scalp location and those signals
then go into a computer and the computer
has software this is where it gets
complicated because some neurofeedback
providers write software but it's
proprietary so nobody knows what
algorithms are going on like that
so there's proprietary neurofeedback we
call those black boxes and sometimes
people get a little twist because I
think it's just respectful it's not it's
just that you're not letting anybody
know what your stuff is but it works I
respect that you want to make money if
you keep it secret so what there's black
box approach
there's straight-up neurofeedback when
you know for example bio explorers one
program thought technology makes it
brain master make software some of the
stuff might be proprietary you basically
see what
doing you know you want to decrease our
for you know you want to increase the
SMR band right so there's those two
different that's that Biff occasion I
use the black box in Afghanistan it's
cygnets a black box its proprietary
except for low what was happening with
the period of neurofeedback how there
was no neuro stimulation there's just
nervous you know for you for how long
was it 10 12 minutes 12 minutes
it was just neurofeedback and then you
stayed up 2 days yeah and slept for 30
minutes in 30 minutes and you were
refreshed yes so so but how is it just
neurofeedback then that caused that I
don't know we don't know and so here's
the problem when I have clients like you
that come and say hey you know I do this
high-stress job I want to do this and
and this is what separates us from all
the other neurofeedback providers and
this is why our company barely makes it
I get asked these questions and what do
you think I say I don't know I don't
know and so but somebody's about to
spend money with you that is not what
they want to hear they don't want to
hear I don't know then I have to explain
that this is for example Signet or or
neural optimal there's a very very
wonderful program by Val and it works
wonders with some people doesn't do jack
with other people same thing with all
systems right they said well how does
this work I so I can't tell you that now
then the army I could get away with that
to some degree not that I'm you know
trying to trying to be stealthy it's
just that nobody would question my
choosing a system to use I only chose it
because that's the one I was introduced
with and we had efficacy at Camp
Pendleton and we had presented results
of the combat operational stress
conference at the Naval Hospital in San
Diego so I we I knew it worked and you
it worked but how it actually that
particular one did what it did I cannot
answer that and it's it's a puzzlement
and it's it's not good to be able to
tell people in the civilian sector I
don't know through just neurofeedback
right which is crazy okay and then so
then taking this to Afghanistan what was
the result of what was happening with
the troops they were that's interesting
nobody's ever asked that question
although I did a presentation on this
several years ago
when I talked to the battalion surgeon
we hate he and I became very close
friends
I got investigated about six months in I
got investigated and it was interesting
because my colonel flew out of Kandahar
to visit and he does that he visits
people and that so there wasn't but we
were high on the profound out we were
high on the priority list because he was
getting pressure from his ups to find
out what was going on because you know
the army army keeps records of
everything right so utilization how many
times your office is being used so
combat stress by psychologists in a
combat environment is not well looked at
because people call us the wizards and
they call us the wizards because we make
people disappear that's why and we do
you come to me and you reveal you've got
all this stuff going on I have to say oh
this dude should not be carrying a rifle
and you get whisked away to Germany and
you're flown home so nobody wants to
talk to us because the wizard will make
you disappear right so this is a very
important point that there is a lot of
stress that's occurring when one is in
those situations and so for for but one
needs to also be we need to have honesty
and transparency and the conversations
that you're having and actually this
this happens even in the entrance
process is making sure that it's so that
the psychology is strong enough to be
able to be in those situations but then
you get into the situations and again
there's another serious and well I would
I would question anybody Santana
learning that there's a screening
process going on I there may be but not
one that I could see but I'm on the flip
side of it okay so we were called
wizards and and and I never I made only
what to people disappear that really
were in serious trouble it wasn't it
wasn't my mo but we looked at that way
my point is that the utilization
clinical utilization combats
tres offices are very very low twelve
fifteen sixteen seventeen percent our
utilization rate was 7080 percent and we
had a waiting list Wow
and that was unheard of and why would
you say that well I can tell you why
because people were doing this and they
were getting to sleep
the battalion surgeon reported a
sixty-two percent reduction in
psychiatric medication prescriptions Wow
people got off sleep meds from
neurofeedback yes yes from just wearing
and EEG no just electrodes on the head
as we know putting electrodes on the
head for 30 minutes yeah a couple times
a week yes
and it was just reading out this is
reading out the bio signals yes and
reflecting it back and maybe is that a
process of just feeling like somebody
cares about my psychology and then I can
sleep better I'm certain that the
placebo effect is in there somewhere but
if you've ever been amped up
seriously amped up you I can pat you on
the knee and tell you you've been great
all you want and you will lay awake till
3:00 in the morning let's be real here
yeah
possi bo effect is real to some degree
but not like this the placebo effect
tends to go to the average baseline we
went way past the baseline to zero so I
mean I mean there's data there to
support that the strength of the effect
was way more than a placebo effect I
think a placebo effect clocks in about
thirty percent thirty thirty five I
can't remember from the literature we
had if efficacy rates of 80 85 90
percent but then we were an extreme
environment too so anything we do is
going to look really awesome right so
let me ask Michael so then is it
potentially that I feel as though my I'm
actually having neurofeedback my brain
is actually being monitored electrically
through electrodes and then that signals
being processed but because of that
feeling that I have I have never done it
have you I've been in eg before you've
never done neurofeedback have you like
have you ever had neurofeedback done
I've had magnetic stimulation but just
for like a tiny
you know I don't think I've had at that
okay because the what you're describing
if you haven't done you interviews
different language okay okay oh you
didn't teach teach yes it's your system
calms down you start breathing more
deeply you feel more physically more
relaxed you oftentimes feel physically
more calm like your brain is probably
spinning thinking about this and that
where's it going to Anam it just all
that [ __ ] stops it just slows down and
you become pretty much present and
centered it's really that simple so it's
like meditation I don't know because I
don't meditate but I think one of the
vets I worked with really summed it up
in a video I have because I recorded him
he was so puzzled how could somebody be
so relaxed and yet so alert and so aware
I don't know if meditation does that
interesting so the image that I use when
I work with people I say imagine they go
what's it kind of like for me alright
you are lying on a Savannah giant lion
and it's hotter than hell out there and
you're under a tree you're just big cat
because everybody knows about cats right
you know watch a lot of YouTube videos
about cats and often the distance you
see a herd of gazelles or a herd of
zebras and all of your lionesses and
they're everybody's just they're hot
it's hot and you're just laying just
perfectly relaxed you got these big open
cat eyes and one gazelle way off in the
distance wanders off and moves and as
you watch this gazelle your eyes go from
this to this mm-hmm and then the gazelle
wanders back and it goes to this mmm
relaxed awareness now if that's
meditation that might be it I don't know
I don't meditate oh that's a really good
description it's a good one
so the what Douglas Daly taught me what
neurofeedback does when you have mural
efficiency for something interesting and
I'm not a mathematician I don't know
math what I've told you at the start of
this I'm not a scientist but a clinical
psychologist yeah but I'm not a
scientist and even a
not a very good clinical psychologist
because they he's humble yeah but they
just they just whatever but the point
being is that let me give you a math
example four plus two equals what six
right so and so how many degrees of
freedom if you saw four plus two equals
with a blank square how many degrees of
freedom does that answer have how many
different answers yeah one or one degree
of freedom okay because it's only one is
four plus x equals six how many degrees
of freedom does that have to possibly oh
there's plenty more oh yeah any more Oh
cuz it could be to all the decimal point
answers so it's like infinity not quite
not quite 4 plus x equals what right
so or 4 plus x equals 6 and then yes can
take a lot of different different values
right that could be infinity it could be
possibly but not it could be but let's
take X plus y equals Z okay that's a lot
of degree that's a lot of degrees of
freedom yeah when you're working with
the EEG like what we do when you are
looking at this one thing becomes very
clear is that the EEG is scale invariant
and that's a very very important concept
Galant scale SOC L scold there Israel
invariant in very yes which means it
doesn't matter what scale you look at
its replicates its pattern so it's like
a fractal right you keep going and going
and going and it's scale invariant it's
one of the reasons why for example cell
phones well back when you were a kid and
I had my first cell phone they had this
really long antenna
yeah and now they're on a phone why are
they on a phone because you can just
micro each the waveform on a on a chip
and it's as long as it's the same the
antenna is the same now you can do it
digitally
so it's scale invariant okay so so the
EEG is also kind of scale invariant so
if you're looking at somebody's really
irelia anxious you will see you know for
example perhaps you might see beta waves
or you might see something else but the
point is that you're seeing energy bound
and if you are able to increase neural
efficiency then the EEG comes like a
bacon sizzle and when it's a bacon
sizzle when it's just when there's
really no form there any state is
possible and just like that lion
you have you can get angry you can get
happy you can say I'm sorry you can say
tell me more about that but if you have
your energy bound up in the e gene kind
of PTSD with this this there and this
there your degrees of freedom are way
less okay okay so the state of relaxed
awareness yes under the tree in the
savanna and also the state of relaxed
awareness as a human enables maximal
degrees of freedom that's absolutely
that's good so so why is that talk too
much Wow I'll also synthesize I'm sorry
really this and played this game of
tennis and this is going very well so I
want to when when we're in a state of
non relaxed awareness our degrees of
freedom are limited we're going to so
degree and then what you have is
repetitive behavioral patterns yes okay
okay so then this if if I haven't done
neurofeedback if I haven't treated my
relaxed whereas if I haven't done a
meditation let's say maybe psychedelics
or whatever it may be that if we haven't
reached the state of getting better and
better at relaxed awareness where we can
kind of ebb and flow between I'm always
one and then I go back to focus and then
all is one and back to focus type thing
that then there's a higher potential
propensity for me to get stuck in these
behavior patterns of sadness or or
anxiety or depression it's but I would
think would you get more stuck in a
repetitive thought pattern period yeah
yeah okay and they they either they keep
playing over and over again it looks
like the anterior cingulate may be a bit
offline a little bit too much slow wave
alpha
even nauseate yourself you know people
often look at depressives people very
very depressed and it's sad to see hello
how stuck we can become in depression
and in some ways it's like the flip side
of narcissism you think about it's two
sides of the same coin
yeah it's a self-referential except
self-referential where dude I'm awesome
and you're not as opposed to
self-referential I'm terrible and you're
great it's still self referential it's
like the same do you sides of the same
coin this this relaxed awareness I'm
just I'm so curious about the studies
then with what was happening with this
in Afghanistan if there's any way to to
teach about what was happening what
studies or who I think the experience
helped that were happening yes so so
then it would it went from a behavior
and thought patterns that had low
degrees of freedom to behavior and
thought patterns that had higher oh well
time now that I don't know I just know
that all started sleeping better okay
we had reductions in anger and we had
curious reductions in anger we had
people that were you cannot in the army
like if you're my soldier I cannot order
you to get mental health treatment can't
do that but I can ball and tell you to
do it Valen Valen you know Alan it's
really becoming a problem that would be
really nice if you were to go down and
see doc be down it now I want to see no
[ __ ] wizard I know yeah but it'd be
really nice a fewer then you can read
between the lines all right you're being
voluntold yeah so we would have
reductions in anger and then we have a
lot of curious things that happens some
extra sensory stuff happened one of the
Redeem when I talk about reductions in
anger though I remember a couple cases
in particular angry angry angry angry
angry came in there did five sessions
with both one was a guy who I think one
was a gal
and and they calm down and they I
remember the guy in particular he says
I'm not doing this [ __ ] anymore
I'm done told me how to do what didn't
tell me he goes they was I was
volunteered to come here for five
sessions so I'm done I'm Ali I'm not
gonna do any more it's like all right
sorry okay no problem so he takes off
right comes back two weeks later I said
sergeant why are you back I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on with everybody
else but they told me I was acting a lot
better I don't see it but they said that
I was acting better so all right I'm
gonna do some more now that to me I was
really curious that's that was really
interesting because I've seen that
before
or somebody insists that there's been
absolutely no change and everybody or
how that goes whoa all right sure fine
there's been no change uh stay like this
and what you are now it's almost as if
like an Einstein relativity thing you're
in a train and you go from Chicago to LA
and you know I'm still in the same train
what are you talking I'm nowhere else
but you've actually so we've seen that
yeah the other thing that we would see
would be a dramatic increase in anger
six seven sessions in the neurofeedback
and that to me was even more clinically
interesting because what are you angry
about I cannot believe I joined the
[ __ ] army I can't believe I married
that woman before I left I can't believe
I'm going back to this and what we were
seeing was mental efficiency where we
were seeing kind of a life life review
well I don't like where I am and how do
I change this when I get back
whoa it was it was extraordinary and we
see this in the clinic sometimes I have
to warn people about this you know
because we've seen marriages dissolve
like I can't believe I married irk I
can't believe I met what why am I still
with this guy yeah let's you start
thinking more clearly more efficiently
you have more degrees of freedom of
choice and you start questioning your
environment so in essence my takeaway
from Afghanistan was this neurofeedback
helps you become the person that
genetically you were meant to be
and I had it I had a chaplain that
wanted to do neurofeedback and he said I
don't know if I should do this I said
what are you worried about goes well
first of all is this [ __ ] gonna make me
gay secondly and when I go back and I'm
am I going to become a Democrat thirdly
am I going to lose my faith in God and
fourthly am I going to believe in this
evolution [ __ ]
and I didn't laugh because they're all
very real legitimate questions I said I
can't answer any of them except the god
question he goes what what do you mean
am I gonna lose my faith in God I said
no no sir you're not gonna lose your
faith in God but I guarantee you that
when you meet God you'll be able to have
a more and if a more intellectual
effective conversation with him or her
because it does near all efficiency and
what we were seeing the reason why we
had the waiting list is that people were
doing it not to sleep better but they
found their physical abilities were
increasing 10 to 12 percent and at that
altitude that meant a lot we had people
that were power lifting that we're
running and finding out that [ __ ] is
great I can work out like I've never
worked out before so it's it's not just
the brain that we're dealing with as an
energy system it's the entire Bayona
yet the whole body whoa
all right yeah I'm just too much mind
blowing so much to process all right so
I don't think I answered your question
do you leave us so much mind blowing has
been happening you did answer the
question okay okay so okay so sooner off
a back causing more relaxed awareness
with a more efficient schooling asleep
and sleeping more efficient just body in
general with physical processes and the
you said that this part was very
profound you said that the neurofeedback
enables you to become we were
genetically meant
I know that sounds rather materialistic
but it's almost as if the real person
starts to emerge and it's wonderful to
see it's really cool to actually see who
you are in 3d of virtual reality as
opposed to a two-dimensional painting on
the wall it's an extraordinarily blessed
process to which it witnessed the
emergence of a true human being that's
what it does
and what what it can do it doesn't do it
all the time
yeah I'm so interested now between
neurofeedback psychedelics meditation
their interplay because there's all they
all seem to do what you're describing
there is a there there is a unique all
of us you've been looking to use this
analogy recently all of us are seeds and
the seeds are all human seeds but the
seeds have a unique DNA within the seed
and that that DNA to fully express
itself in the world needs the right
nutrients for the seed the air food
water love compassion etc and then the
expression of that is the fruits that
the that the seed the tree can make and
those fruits for the self for the
community the family the civilization at
large and so when we see ourselves in a
2d like a painting versus when we see
ourselves in the way that were meant to
express ourselves in the world in turn
our fullest we'd like you said we kind
of put all of the degrees of freedom and
to question all the sudden it wasn't
just two degrees of freedom who I've
married where I'm at right now in life
that's pretty much it I'm always
following this versus seeing though all
of the options that exist that we could
collapse at any moment we could choose
to move into a different career you
could choose to move into a different
relationship we could choose to move
cities etc all this different these
different choices that we have so is
that a
decent way of framing it - works for you
sure okay
yeah and would you say that that framing
also would you agree with it or there's
something wants to it no I don't think
it's you know the words are the words
they okay they you're attempting to
describe using a very linear thing
called language a complex field effect
fair yeah and one of the things I
learned from five Meo mmm was um we have
to talk about one of the things I
learned I mean one of the things they
have to reconcile and I don't know if
I'm gonna get my evolutionary biology
correct but I think us in our form right
now - ah me and brain wise I've pretty
much been the same for about maybe 200
250 thousand years okay and I know other
brilliant people have talked about this
before but I've always been struck that
the emergence of language is so recent
so recent in our times its what 50 60
thousand years when language really
emerged I think I might be wrong might
be a little bit longer sure sure but the
point is that in the anatomy might have
been there prior to it but the point is
that there was a time in our history
there was a long time in our history
where we didn't have language and yet we
built and communicated we made it we
hunted we ate we raised kids together
and in my not the first one but the
second five experience that I had
fortunately I got really terrified
halfway through it and I tasted it and
confidence back most of it out which was
a great thing because I was able to
maintain a little bit more in this plane
and as I looked around I realized that
you know here these psychedelic people
would say you're on Genesis no I thought
I heard neurogenesis one more time I was
either gonna take a [ __ ] or puke it just
really gets me annoyed oh you know 5ml
creates new pathways dude no it doesn't
and the pathway it's not like a frickin
freeway that you cut through a mountain
and besides that nature is very
efficient
and she's not going to create a new
pathway if old ones exist and when I
began to wonder where the other pathways
other to probably stored holograms
actually in our in our in our neural
network system that are submitted of
other ways of communicating
energetically because I remember in that
state when I looked at Sandra who was my
guide at that time I looked at her
shoulder I reached over you know it's
not like it first I was part of my
conscious brain would go hey dude this
is really pervy right you know don't be
doing this I just reached over and
looked and went like this and said what
happened and she said oh that's where I
had an old broken bone and I could like
see it I saw this red kind of angry vibe
Mike I'm not real happy with you like a
petulant child
and that's like all right and I was so
struck by that and and how and then as I
joined clothing what's this through the
clothing yes yeah it was just kind of
there and and I remember trying to speak
and the image came to me of how speaking
to somebody is like taking a 20 pound
sack of potatoes and throwing it on
their lap it's a very violent intrusive
thing that demands attention with no
finesse and I became and this was so
striking to me because you know I
studied English literature at Berkeley
and I I loved language and I loved the
way words work and I began to realize
how brutish and how forceful and how
intrusive language is compared to these
other ways we must have had of knowing
okay yes
the depth of communication prior to
languages it was it was pervasive and
when you think about the heart you know
heart puts out this EMF field of what
you know two to three meters around this
room it's just a meter I always got the
meters and feet confused I don't know
I am wondering though what those other
ways we had a community and I don't
think everybody was doing five and
communicating or anything like that I
just think that we had other ways of
interacting that were profoundly
effective and efficient as more so than
language possibly you know when language
rose up and it became the sexy star of
the cortex and get a lot of [ __ ] done
very very quickly there's no doubt about
it and I like it and I also wonder about
this other ways these other ways yeah
yeah I agree
this is why this current argument that's
permeating through scientific
communities as well as just globally of
that this is the absolute best time to
be alive above that I think there's very
fascinating things about our past that
we have that we're very ignorant of and
that I think it's difficult to just make
a binary statement about how things are
today compared to how they were pre
language being invented this EMF field
at the heart none is a part of also just
just being emotive or expressive with
facial expressions in general without
using the voice and you're right it's
just this thing that the cortex is so
excited about language efficiencies
creating with that and maybe that's some
of the reasons why we see such ailments
with climate change wealth inequality
things like that we just didn't vibe
from the heart as we built as much as we
vibe from the language in the cortex
potentially yeah
yes okay let's do let's do the what's
actually do is we could talk forever
let's talk about Alpha Theta Center so
since Afghanistan coming back here this
is in San Diego Alpha Flight Center okay
so what have you been doing since then
with neurofeedback learning as much as
possible I don't like saying I don't
know and I have learned since then I've
literally learned how to interpret it
sounds like tarot cards it kind of is
like tarot cards you know the raw EEG 19
channels I worked with a brilliant
brilliant mentor Jay Jay gum Coleman
that brain science international he's
one of the top EEG people in the world
can read and understand and so we look
at the EEG not that a neurologist would
look at the same way what we look at
they would they would be dismissive of
there's no giant epileptic spikes you
know we're not looking for that we're
looking for we're looking for possibly
slowed out from the frontal cortex or we
are wondering about low-power and very
fast alpha which is tends to be a
signature of people who drink or
alcoholics you know high arousal system
systems over arouse it's over amped we
will get so I've had to learn that and
sometimes we'll get referrals from
psychiatrists you know ADHD right kids
get on ADHD to get put on strattera they
could put it up put on concerta
and and and and I remember several cases
I had where oh you know maybe the kids
got 88 she's been diagnosed and he acts
like a bastard now he's like is really
an [ __ ] at school well that's not the
parent description but when you extract
their underlying frustration you can
tell that they would probably throttle
the kid that kid throwing the loss
against it right
and so we would map the kid and find out
that his rare alpha was clocking at
eleven point five Hertz which is
extraordinarily fast that's not the
Hertz of somebody working at Walmart
being a greeter no disrespect that's
that's fast and what we also see then
we say this wonderful 1617 Hertz bump
right in the in the in the middle up
here at 16 17 Hertz there's a lot of the
fuel is there so we got a fast engine we
got fast fuel and maybe not a best you
know a best neurophysiological signature
for a seal and navy seal you want
somebody to be fast at the back but you
don't want to be too fast cuz then you
get over aroused but you need that
central bump to know when to pull the
trigger or not pull the trigger same
thing with a CEO you need that sharp
fastness but you also need that bump to
be able to take the risk or not take the
risk so you give a kid like that
strattera what does it do it bumps up
the rear alpha in other Hertz and a half
so instead of being 11 1/2 12 13 Hertz
he's just just coming out of his skin so
we were able these days more and more to
have a gentle conversations with medical
doctors and psychiatrists because we
don't prescribe and we have to couch our
words carefully because I'm not saying
you shouldn't take your medication you
might want to have a conversation with
your provider and look at these studies
and instead maybe you might want to take
an SSRI oh you know I don't I'm not I'm
not I'm not depressed well yes but an
SSRI will naturally lower frontal alpha
because your rear stuff is really in
good shape it's got a little bit too
much frontal alpha going on
that's probably interfering with some of
your you know cognition and whatnot so
we're able to kind of look at the
neurophysiology of signatures these days
and we're able to kind of maybe suggest
you might want to look at an SSRI or or
an snr I and one of the things that
we've because of Jays influence on the
company and his profound knowledge about
the EEG and sleep the mammalian brain
should be able to stay awake for 10
minutes and not do this and when you see
this a being and flowing of vigilance
model which is out of the European
school of thought on EEG modeling you
see a waxing and waning of states and
it's an on part because people aren't
sleeping very very well so we're able to
you know we have people come in that say
you know I sleep great and ninety
seconds into an eyes open
according we're seeing a vertex wave at
C Z which is a fancy way of seeing it
saying we're seeing stage 2 sleep happen
in the brain eyes open nobody home at 90
seconds so we call that a precipitous
descent into sleep there's no going
through a 1 a 2 there's nothing like
you're there right away so we we look at
this and then we take it the next level
and we we use some very good tools out
of sport Center for computational
neuroscience and we run an independent
component analysis on after we clean up
the artifact we cleaned the artefact the
eye blinks out then we look at kind of
more what we think might be the real
brainwave activity with the blink on the
breathing gone the muscles gone are you
holding this like this all that your
brow like this all that produces what we
call EMG so we extract that
mathematically out and we're left with a
more clean recording and then we run
independent component analysis which is
a way of looking at areas within the
brain within the brain not at the
surface this is where my field has
really gone astray and unfortunately
they're wandering in the desert and
those of you listening out there where
are you over there yes I'm sorry but
scalp locations are not where it's at
you want signal source locations that's
what you want signal source locations
those of you who think that scalp
topography is the be-all end-all don't
ever my shouldn't say they're gonna be
dinosaurs they're not gonna be dinosaurs
but nobody's going to go to them because
it's ineffective so we the difference
again is I'm sorry the difference again
is people get hung up that thinking that
where that where this where the
electrode is on the scalp is where the
activity is and nothing could be further
from the truth
electrodes are nothing more than
antennas that pick up every damn signal
whether it's biophysical or mechanical
everything if even if I were record your
brain in this room with this equipment
going we are going to get a 60 Hertz
buzz somewhere in that recording so we
have to extract once we extract that out
people like Tony Bell at Bell
Laboratories and Terry Sinofsky I can't
pronounce this name Scott McKay they
absolutely opened the
Teodoro cuz they said what if we take
those signals and what if we
mathematically work with them and
maximize independence temporal
independence and separate these signals
the same thing your iPhone does it it's
called a cocktail party problem it's the
same thing if you can source signal you
can separate the signals out it's
digital signal processing you do it with
this stuff you take out this light you
can take out this well we can do that
with brainwaves and what we're left with
is then we actually there's information
on spatial it's a spatial filter and we
can localize these components within the
brain and see where this energy to use
the new term or slow alpha is activated
and it's extraordinarily interesting
because now we get a window into where
the functionality of the brain is now we
can start mapping symptoms to brain
regions that's what Tim and I were
talking about downstairs regions of
interest using Loretto you know low
resolution and electro tomography I
think is what it is we are actually able
with Maxwell's equations to reverse
engineering and I'm fortunately I don't
know the linear algebra my friends have
been very patient with me trying to
teach it to me but I feel like snug on a
midsummer night's dream when he said
would you please speak slowly for I am
slow of study yeah I don't get it but we
can do it and so we use very
sophisticated software and mathematical
techniques to image into the brain look
at where the problems are and we try
whether we're right or wrong to enter
that area on the scalp location by
targeting certain frequencies and we can
do this non-invasively with us with it
with a cap we don't need a cap I just
need three four electrons three four
electrodes and you just place them on
regions of interest well you need a
reference a reference yeah all right and
then you need an area that you'd like to
Train in an area that you're using as a
reference but the people I work with
also say that that's [ __ ] that
they're both picking up the same signal
so neural feedback in the people I work
with and they're very
very very very smart people they agree
that it works but in their opinion and I
have come to share it it is exactly like
Chinese medicine it works and we don't
know how it works and what we've been
doing at our centre because we've been
gathering so much data and that's what I
was talking with Tim a little bit about
earlier down there we have gathered so
many EEG s that we are struggling we
want to see what is how does it work you
know how is neurofeedback working
there's different types how is it that I
could take 1012 minutes of a session and
not sleep for two days and be perfectly
fine about it it didn't even suffer for
it later it was great how is this
possible how is it possible to do alpha
theta and feel like you've gone into
your past and you've talked with your
mother and had a conversation and come
out of it and go wow I feel so much
better
how much does that sound like ayahuasca
right so how is the how are these things
possible not invasively without any
medicines so we don't have answers for
your questions and I'm really sorry Alan
at least I don't and there's other
people that might answer better than
Maeve so talk to them yeah there's still
so much to actually be able to
understand
okay so then part of the neurofeedback
process is being able to being able to
make sorts of analysis from the
neurofeedback and make now let me help
there's no recommendation supplement
health care first of all we do a brain
map we analyze the brain map and we
create pretty pictures from the brain
map and we look at things within the raw
and then from there we say it looks like
there's too much frontal alpha we just
need to reduce that so we'll put
electrode here electrode here maybe run
bio explore thought technology software
the person will watch a movie I usually
use the Brandenburg Concertos or
Fleetwood Mac I usually train to music
like Cirque du Soleil I train to visual
things in the screen well shrink go up
the volume will go up and down
according to what the brain does so for
asking you to make less frontal alpha
screen does this if you I'm sorry if you
didn't it get bigger because you're
doing what we want it to do so we can
inhibit or enhance and all this happens
prior to your awareness so you have no
conscious control over this because at
its core like 100 millisecond delay
right but at its core the brain is a
novelty detection device the brain is
designed to help us meet the need needs
of the immediate moment so any deviation
from that moment kicks in the knot it
kicks in this novelty it's like cuts
calling in 100 P 300 waveform so the
moment that thing starts a shift brain
recognizes that like well what's that
now this is where it gets a little
technical a little interesting your
raise your eyes are glazing over my I'm
trying to keep up this is this is so
interesting so the last last bit here
because it kind of helps puts if you
have a whale in an ocean it stands on
its head and emits a song how far away
is that song heard just through the
water yeah how far how far how water I
can't tell the sound wave stops yeah you
got a whale singing a song in the middle
of an ocean how long how far away do you
think you could be to hear that
no no maybe a mile it goes it goes quite
a ways okay miles yeah so you've got
this whale emitting this very
low-frequency boom right kind of like
contact whales sing whales sing
low-frequency Oh show you
high energy low frequency high energy
okay high frequency low energy okay this
is a one over F power distribution this
is kind of like a fundamental law of the
universe low frequency tends to be
associated with higher power than high
frequency dolphin squeaks can't hear it
very far away the brain behaves the same
way why because it is metabolically
efficient and if it can learn that it
doesn't have to make that low frequency
but it can make this and still get the
job done
it starts reorganizing its
it's the only thing to writes its own
damn software it's - sounding and we
have no clue how this happens but
generally the e so I can use less
metabolic processing to capture since
almost a similar amount of it if I asked
you to get me a cup of coffee right now
and you jumped up kicked your stuff over
ran out there ran downstairs got a cup
of coffee
kick down the door and ran here and gave
me my coffee you would have accomplished
the mission with a tremendous
expenditure of energy yeah so think
about this behaviorally or you could
have gone down there very quietly come
back up but the coffee down with minimal
expenditure of energy relaxed awareness
but speed relaxed awareness that's not
that's not confused my my poor metaphor
here all right it's relaxed awareness so
the brain is wanting to be metabolically
efficient it wants to follow that power
distribution curve because it's very
efficient that way the way the interplay
between physics biology and
communication within the brain is
astounding and we're only stand or not
even standing at the shores or like in
lifeboats and I think we can walk across
part of that water to get there on the
shore
it's astounding so when we're doing
neural feedback essentially what we're
moving that brain towards is that one
over half power distribution making the
brain more efficient making the brain
more efficient okay yeah it's kind of
cut it came home at least with its you
know Oh point zero zero one percent
understanding for me I'm forever I'm
sorry I'm no no no no for no I am much
Shemp at trying to understand and so for
others I think it's easier to understand
no it's not that's why I have my
assistant talk to people because I talk
too much
and then they get your your action no no
actually my mind has been expanded its
awareness multiple times in very
profound ways from this conversation so
you've done an exceptional job teaching
me but I'm very humbly saying that only
point zero zero one percent I understand
that's my point of why I say that and
also because I think like you just
described there's just so
much we're still ignorant of and so I'm
trying my best to help other people
understand how much we are ignorant of
just like you are with what you said so
wish I knew and stuff and just raw
intelligence ability to to like for
example someone like Tim or you that
have been in the industry for so long
you can talk jargon industry jargon for
days no problem sometimes yes with
others I try and synthesize and make I
appreciate and you actually have very
good analogies your analogies have been
very strong and even all the way to like
the way you were saying about language
and and there was just so many good ones
throughout the conversation I mean
there's still so much to understand
about neuro efficiency I mean we'll have
to do another conversation on this on
the subject here at San Diego so we'll
have to you know next time you come up
to San Francisco or when we go down
there we'll have to revisit the
conversation so much but but in general
it's your the the alpha-beta Center does
neuro efficiency training yes we hope we
hope goal okay okay okay and not through
neuro stimulation just your nerves no we
use that as well too because when you
stimulate the brain you're actually
sometimes priming the pump particularly
with tDCS and you it's the same thing
you know if if somebody is micro dosing
and then we stimulate and we do
neurofeedback I mean they're choosing to
do that on their own you're priming the
brain and you're really kind of tickling
other networks that are latent in the
background and so we are seeing kind of
a deep deep deeper I don't know what an
interesting type of learning if you ever
had an experience where you kind of
stare at your hand yeah and you winnow
into your hand and you're like tripping
on your handle it's amazing what it is
so imagine the brain is doing that with
a video that's shifting in relationship
to its own being okay yeah that's the
closed-loop feedback no it's not closed
loop it's not
that's called neural feedback okay I
don't know why why maybe it's for patent
processes that been
or Adam is calling a closed loop but
it's neurofeedback neurofeedback yeah
got it so instead of adding clothes
would be us-- unnecessary it's just
nervous
it's just neurofeedback it's more of a
that's more of a scientific accurate
description of what's happening but
neurofeedback the same thing here and
and and what the brain will do the
attentional process it brings during
after a stem or after a micro dose is is
really interesting we think there's
something there and maybe someday we'll
understand it it potentially becomes
more efficient yeah yeah and potentially
by visiting Alpha Theta Center and going
through this process of of doing
something like what you do with the
visual adjustment that auditory
adjustments and the physio and the any
neurofeedback person can do this okay
we're not that special cool cool yeah
okay just two quick questions on the way
out first question is are we in a
simulation
no I do not think so I think that's I
think that's pretty narcissistic so and
I don't think so because what I have to
reconcile is of course it could have
been created in a simulation one could
always argue this right but what I have
to reconcile is that we've had life on
this planet for millions and hundreds of
millions of years before quote
consciousness appeared so you want to
explain that so in your right it could
be simulation because we're simulating
that so I you know the circularity
becomes it becomes endless but no I
really don't think so because I have a
hard time and we talk about the heart
once and how you know consciousness is
this well what about the dinosaurs 100
200 billion years you know I I don't
know it something feels rather self
referential about the simulation theory
and then what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is to feel the facets of love and
gratitude they're there they're there
not quite two sides of the same coin but
their facets on a wonderful Jama I think
to experience that is is transcendent
and mystical yeah this has been such a
fun conversation cause you're great
answers I want to know more about the
effect of like five having me or DMT on
what the research has been but we'll
have to do that again yeah we've we've
modeled some interesting States I don't
think anybody has done the type of data
that we've done I think even Tim was
surprised when I said that but we what
we've what we've pulled out and like on
the my computer I mean we've we've got
the modeling of what what happens we
have the 10-minute baseline on several
of the videos that we animated using is
is plug-in when you see the components
firing with information Gregor causality
and then you see it's 600 seconds which
is 10 minutes you see the hit right the
person takes the inhalation within 20
milliseconds you see this radical
shifting transformation of active
inhibition that's what we were talking
about when you walked up that the brain
is actively inhibiting itself and that
is astounding to me it's actively not
communicating and in that silence
something wonderful emerges yeah so I'll
have to talk what do you think is the
wonderful thing that emerges in that
silence I think the magic of
consciousness is in the interplay
between empty spaces so Pam mentioned
that the magic of music I think is the
space between notes uh-huh
I think there's there's a very deep
truth in that because we saw 12 I was
explaining to him I said we saw the
power drop out across the cortex that
makes no sense
intuitively you're going oh my god I'm
visiting this I mean that she's teaching
me about my mother I'm realizing this
I'm realizing that I'm throwing up I am
I'm hearing the sound of creation I'm
witnessing infinite fractals of
iterations of spirits before me
that's what's going on in there but I'm
telling you out here we're just like
June it's a tremendous drop in power and
it's astounding and that's why I
mentioned it that's I was wondering my
kind of secret theory is is this an
example of stochastic resonance which is
when you take a very very faint signal
and how you amplify it is that you flood
it with random noise think about it if
you take a very very faint signal like a
very degraded photograph and convert it
digitally you amplify with random noise
your your random 5 Hertz it's going to
enhance the existing 5 Hertz and make it
come up more you see what I'm saying
and it's a it's a tool used I think in
Photoshop even or the NSA definitely
uses it to extract license numbers but
you take a faint signal Venice or flood
it with random noise you're going to
enhance the inherent signal signal and I
think one of the things that we suspect
least we there's no there's no Royal way
there's no like I'm a part of some
weenus maybe it's just me and me is that
the inherent noise and the brain is
vital to our consciousness the inherent
noise of little tiny things happening I
think in the psychedelic state that
noise is not noise there's inherent
information in there that gets amplified
and gets experienced that's where I
think the secret is or one of the
pathways forward and understanding this
stuff and that could potentially also be
an analogy with our obsessive use of the
technology every time there's a moment
of silence and our lives and so if we
were to not use the technology in those
little moments there that would give the
space for that to come up it's not that
unusual and then just let me just say
this little bit here 1797 William
Wordsworth wrote a beautiful series of
poems expostulation and reply I think
it's either 1797 or 1798 and I don't
know those don't have the poem memory is
thinking and I just know it a little bit
of it but his friend comes up to him in
the poem and says dude
right right you just sitting there
wasting your time by this lake come on
you know go read books man this is where
it's all at
I mean I'm paraphrasing it but um he
responds he says there's something like
the I cannot choose but see the ear
cannot choose but here our bodies will
feel what it will with or against our
will
so why should I be seeking when I and
wise passiveness here can learn more and
more 'l and of evil then all the sages
can teach me so that notion of wise
passiveness in attention or in
meditation listening enables I think he
was spot-on
because to me you know that people like
I'm sorry here you're generations all
we've invented this we've got this like
you know 1798 William Wordsworth was
sitting by a lake and then wise
passiveness feeling the vibe of what's
important and learning yeah even
Shakespeare hints at this in his
writings I mean when Glouster was
blinded you know and his son said hey
let me help you you know I have no way
because when I had eyes I could not find
my way or something like that so they
had put his eyes out and he was feeling
sorry says no wait I have eyes I still
was lost now that I have no eyes I know
where I'm going so there is something
about wise passiveness about meditation
about silence about and I think in
psychedelics what's happening is that
the practicality of lowering certain
power levels in the brain emerges a
different type of knowing to emerge yeah
that's great allowing a different type
of knowing to merge through the silence
yes through the wise past what passive
wise passive really really Morris was
expostulation replies 1797
lines written to tintern abbey I think
you should read that
it's beautiful it really nails that
experience he really came back at him
and said his friend in his place yeah
damn that's so good that's so good
so and maybe that piece feedbacks is
important because you know tune this off
go and do some why a wise passiveness I
love that I love that we're big
proponents of that I'm sure we talked
about that quite a lot so right holy cow
Michael thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much well so much a
fascinating conversation thank you
your wealth of wisdom we have to have
you back to unpack more there's so much
to talk about all right I love it huge
thank you everyone for tuning in we
would greatly appreciate love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode also check out the links in
the bio below is it Alpha Theta Center
yeah
Alpha Theta Center calm is the link in
the bio check that out
also check out the rest of Michael's
links as well I'm going to talk more to
your families your communities your
co-workers people online on social media
about neural efficiency what we talked
about today and also check out the links
below to consciousness hacking all set
the simulation support the artists
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace bye